Сім кам'яних блоків і всюди червоно-біло-зелені кольори національного прапора Угорщини.
Кожен блок нагадує про одне із семи угорських племен.
Пам'ятник височіє над Карпатами, на території України.
Негусто заселені долини до кінця Першої світової війни належали Угорщині.
Допоки їх Тріанонським договором не передали іншій державі.
Ми знаємо, що Тріанонський договір повернути вже не можна.
Кароліна Дорчі - одна зі 150-ти тисяч етнічних угорців, які живуть на Закарпатті.
У реформованій церкві моляться та співають лише угорською.
Кароліна щонеділі ходить на службу.
Вона активна громадська діячка у Береговому.
На місцевому угорському консульстві годинники показують час за Будапештом та за Брюсселем.
Час за Києвом - застиг.
Неподалік розпочинається фестиваль, співорганізаторкою якого є Кароліна.
Її вимога - культурна автономія.
Ми просто хочемо, щоб дали нам жити, щоб ми могли берегти свою культуру,
могли спілкуватися своєю рідною мовою, щоб дали спокій нашим школам.
Утім, саме в цьому питанні нависла загроза, вважають у Береговому.
Фестиваль от-от розпочнеться.
Кароліна хоче переконатися, що все готово, та сподівається, що не дощитиме,
адже колонки та електроприлади мають стояти перед сценою.
У фестивальній ході бере участь і закарпатський губернатор, представник президента у регіоні.
Він і чути нічого не хоче про прагнення місцевих угорців до автономії
і страхи, що його область може віддокремитися.
Хай Київ розбереться там у своїх проблемах.
І не говорить абсолютно ніхто дурниць.
Тому що ніякого сепаратизму нема, не було і не може бути.
Та коли грають національні гімни, український тут майже ніхто не співає. Мовчазний сепаратизм.
Назад до консульства. Тут мобілізувалися противники будь-якого сепаратизму.
Вони вимагають вислати угорського консула.
Вимоги зачитує український націоналіст Василь Вовкунович.
Його обурює це відео, зняте прихованою камерою.
На ньому в угорському консульстві у Береговому українцям видають угорські паспорти.
Так Будапешт таємно посилює свій контроль на Закарпатті.
Це українська земля, українська держава де-факто, де-юре.
Але в такому побутовому, як є, то трошки важко визначити.
Дехто вважає, що це є вже кусочок Угорщини, якщо не тепер, то через років 5-10 буде.
Кароліна вбачає загрозу в українських націоналістах,
які, на її думку, весь час підливають олію у вогонь.
На початку року хтось підірвав офіс угорської культурної спілки у регіоні.
Причини і зловмисники досі не звстановлені. На щастя, ніхто не постраждав.
Університет у Береговому - капітально відремонтований.
Кароліна Дорчі викладає тут політологію.
Вона та її колеги отримують зарплату від Угорщини, яка повністю фінансує цей університет.
Новий мовний закон дуже зіпсував настрій угорській національній меншині.
Київ хоче більше шкільних уроків українською, а отже може зменшитися кількість годин угорської.
От цей закон "Про освіту", це означає, що Україна не хоче нам давати ті права,
які в Конституції зафіксовані.
У суперечку втрутився і уряд у Будапешті - як захисник нацменшини.
Уже десятки тисяч людей на Заході України отримали громадянство Угорщини.
Чи має угорський паспорт Кароліна, жінка говорити не хоче. Боїться.
Я не хочу на це відповідь давати.
Ну потім СБУ мене буде викликати.
Багато закарпатців переймаються своєю культурною ідентичністю.
Інші ж бояться сепаратизму у прикордонних регіонах.
Напруга, яку тут посіяла ще Перша світова війна.
Хоча регіон - 100 років потому - міг би стати містком між Східною і Західною Європою.